oh my gosh i forgot we could have showed
like i can do human holding i'm going to
do that on youtube
are you ready for this yeah okay
so you're going to stand like this
i'm going to use you okay so you're
going to come over here and bring this
arm down actually like this and you're
going to hold it like that okay there
you go on the side yeah you're the
anchor so i'm going to come over here i
just want you to think about bracing
yourself stick your legs a little wider
i'm going to be pulling this way so
think about going that way
[Laughter]
all right so i'm going to do a human
poultry remember that shoulder mount
move i did where i flipped upside down
on the pole yep all right that's one
thing
okay your grandmother right over there
here we go
feel your penis on the side of my neck
sorry
my
this is unbelievable